i'm vinnie from double shot at love
what's up i'm dj pony d and we are
reading your thirstiest tweets whip
buzzfeed
i want a boyfriend with the face of
vinnie from jersey shore
the body of vinnie from jersey shore and
the personality of vinnie from jersey
shore
that's so sweet that works out because
you have all three and why am i always
single if there's people out there that
feel like this i would let pauly d split
me open whoa
that is artistic right there yeah i mean
i appreciate that this next one's for
both of us the only men i'd let run a
train on me are vinnie and pauly d
choo-choo
bringing us back to our old old ways
that's all right uh yeah i appreciate
that i really appreciate that
we share everything yeah
i hope vinnie from jersey shore knows he
is the love of my life and i will wait
for him forever because i will die if
i'm with someone else i need vinnie well
don't die i know like i'm okay but i'm
not worth that all that yes
i'd let pointy scoop my insides out and
bake a pie with them i love pie i love
desserts i'm a sweets guy you know that
that is the creative pickup line that
i've never heard before is it keto pie
so this one's for both of us and it says
who is your ultimate eiffel tower and
why is it pulling the invinci
this is taken back to the hallways bro
we're eiffel towering through zoom
no i know guys come on me and paulie
we're changed men now okay like a
relationship this guy's looking for love
man i don't speak french i want to eat
paulie d and vinnie's hulls what can i
say it's good hole all right pauly d
please sit that ass on my sideburns
hey me and you are in a promited
relationship and uh you're not saying
that ass on anyone else's sideburns is
that mine are there mothers watching
these tweets
i guess not i want vinnie from jersey
shore to rail my
oh hmm
ooh that could get messy i'm a hard pass
on that one i'm going to ask paulie d if
he will fist pump my ass
i would say yeah but you don't fish pump
anymore yeah i'm used to like beating
that beat up you know what i mean
that sounds painful
yeah all right still to this day dj
pauly d can choke slam me into next week
and clog my ear pipes
do that creativity that creativity like
that is very yeah graphic it's not just
it's not just a punch in the face
and yo are you sure we're getting these
tweets because i haven't seen them
[Laughter]
it finally happened i finally had the
dream where i have a [ __ ] threesome
with dj paulie d and vinnie i've never
felt more fulfilled
and send tweet well i'm glad i was a
dream and not a nightmare poorly d and
vinnie could [ __ ] my [ __ ] up and double
me so hard my spine breaks who follows
these people that they're talking like
this and then spine breaks that's
dangerous
danger yeah
i mean you're going to have back issues
the rest of your life and that sounds
like a lawsuit to me holy day's so fine
i'd suck his left toe while he pushed me
from behind
i do have pedicure toes you'd have to be
really flexible though
hmm i just
gotta uh i would have to like wrap
around the corner i don't know i want
pauly d to murder my [ __ ] i'm assuming
let me see the other word with the p oh
it's an ass [ __ ]
tell us we get really jealous
yeah you know we don't support murder
either
vinnie was always my fave on jersey
shore but vinnie with a beard daddy
yeah the beard the beard changes the
game fun fact about that beard it took
um
about 20 something years to grow
oh i'm still growing this from season
one
looks good man
so i want pulid to dj my [ __ ] because
they know these hands
you would give the ultimate orgasm with
those fingers i have really fast hands
man
and at us next time come on yeah all
right that was fun thank you so much
buzzfeed yes thank you for having us
make sure to tune in to mtv for a brand
new season a double shot i love season
three
[Music]
you